Jon Cryer's career has had a lot of
twists and turns over the decades but
you may be shocked to learn that at one
point he was asked to star in Quentin
Tarantino's violent classic Reservoir
Dogs
Jon Cryer's long career in the
entertainment industry began in the
1980s when he was still a teenager after
debuting in the romantic comedy no small
Affair alongside to me more in 1984. he
catapulted to Fame in the 1986 John
Hughes classic Pretty in Pink as the
iconic 80s nerd ducky yet in the decades
following his movie debut crier
gradually appeared in fewer and fewer
films with Superman for the quests for
peas and Hot Shots being some of the few
big projects He was involved in by the
90s he had transitioned mostly to
television roles but while he remained
in demand as a guest star his attempts
to headline the series all flopped with
all of his shows quickly canceled almost
two decades after his film debut crier
suddenly had a career Resurgence when he
landed the role of Allen in the hit
sitcom Two and a Half Men starting in
2003 the long-running comedy series was
on air for an impressive 12 Seasons
before it ended in 2015. the part earned
him two Emmys one for outstanding
supporting actor in a comedy series in
2009 and another as lead actor in 2012
but even years before the show's finale
there were major controversies that
dragged the production down one of the
most notorious controversies was the
chaotic departure of Pryor's co-star
Charlie Sheen in 2011. Executives at
Warner Brothers television fired the
actor who is currently a wash and
Scandal for too many missed rehearsals
forgetting lines and for simply making
the set a toxic work environment the
negative press surrounding the series
then continued with the damaging remarks
of actor Angus Jones who called it filth
and begged viewers to stop watching the
show lived on for a while after the exit
of Sheen with Ashton Kutcher brought on
board to boost ratings but after four
seasons anchored by crier and Kutcher
the network finally pulled the Plug In
2015. following the conclusion to the
Two and a Half Men series John Cryer
secured an iconic role as the infamous
villain Lex Luthor in Supergirl in 2018
crier was featured in 20 episodes during
the last few seasons of the super
heroines show and he also made an
appearance as the legendary super
villain in several others of the GC
arrowverse including Arrow Batwoman The
Flash and DC's Legends of tomorrow when
Supergirl ended in 2021 though so did
crier's time as Lex Luthor even though
fans hoped he might continue the role in
the series Superman Lois Luther was
ultimately recast the former Walking
Dead star Michael cutlets took on the
role instead crier cleared the air about
the recasting by posting on Twitter
sharing for the record the folks at DC
were very cool and gave me a heads up
that the show was going a different way
with the character before they started
looking most of the time actors learn
about this stuff when it comes out in
the trades I'm grateful they were classy
about it in 2011 while still starring on
Two and a Half Men crier accepted the
lead role in the animated Pixar film
planes at the time the actors seemed
ecstatic about the news as he told ET to
be a part of a Disney movie is a blast
because every person has that connection
with Disney movies that they had as a
kid being a part of a Disney movie is
something I have always wanted to do
when this opportunity presented itself I
just jumped on board but just a few
months before the scheduled release of
the movie in summer 2013 the studio
announced that Dane Cook had replaced
crier no explanation for the switch was
given though director Clay Hall
emphasized in a press release that the
edition of cook would give the main
character Dusty both a quick wit and an
edge ultimately though the film was a
critical failure it did well enough to
earn a sequel which also starred cook
probably the most substantial reason
that Jon Cryer hasn't appeared much in
entertainment news recently is simply
because his new comedy show on NBC
hasn't come out yet in 2022 it was
announced that crier would be executive
producing and headlining a new comedy
that set to co-star Donald Faison and
Abigail Spencer so far though the show
hasn't begun filming yet or even been
given a name much less a firm release
date the family comedy will be about the
complicated nature of life with kids
after a divorce and the drama that can
rise even as the former couple gets
along it's far too early to speculate
about how the show will perform or
whether it will have legs on the network
but if it's a hit crier will be back in
the spotlight for another sitcom success
early in his career there were several
major roles early on that crier
auditioned for but didn't get any one of
which could have significantly altered
the trajectory of his career Pryor
auditioned for the lead role in the 1985
classic Back to the Future but was
ultimately rejected in favor of Michael
J fox he was also asked to audition for
the role of Mr Pink and Quentin
Tarantino's 1992 classic Reservoir Dogs
but crier declined because he didn't
fully understand the script Steve
Buscemi cut the job instead Pryor later
realized his mistake telling Howard
Stern he still regretted the decision
just had to beg off and not audition for
and then funding a brilliant movie he
also auditioned for the part of Chandler
and friends but he told James Corden
that his audition tape didn't make it to
the producers in time and she packaged
up the tape of me doing my best Chandler
bang sent it to Los Angeles and it got
stuck at custody he soon said that he
loves Matthew Perry's performance on the
show Pryor told Howard attorney he would
have been decent as Chandler but not up
to Perry's level which took the sting
out of losing the role he said when I
see a an actor hit it out of the park
it's like well of course no wonder they
gave it to that guy during the writer's
Guild of America's strike in 2007 when
all of Hollywood was effectively shut
down Two and a Half Men was one of the
numerous Productions put on hold but Jon
Cryer didn't simply take a break from
work during this period instead he
showed solidarity with his fellow
creatives by participating in the
massive lever action Pryor told a
socialite's life it's sad that this has
been really hard for a lot of people
most of the crew on our show are really
gonna miss the money end with Christmas
coming up this is just hellish but I
really feel like their anger which is
absolutely Justified should be directed
at the studios they've been intransigent
and ridiculous in the negotiations
just as John Cryer's time as Alan Harper
was coming to a close with the end of
Two and a Half Men the actor completed
his Memoir so that happened released in
2015 the book tells the story of working
in Hollywood from his perspective along
with the important relationships he's
formed with other stars in the industry
such as Charlie Sheen Demi Moore Molly
Ringwald and many more as crier
explained on Good Morning America it was
his manager and agent that approached
him with the idea to tell his tale which
the actor reluctantly agreed to only
after the duo secured a book deal for
him a particular note in the book is his
discussion of Sheen's Infamous meltdown
and firing from Two and a Half Men
Charlie made the choice that that was
not the life he wanted anymore cars said
that he'd reached out to Sheen about
writing the book and that his old
co-star was supportive of him outside of
his career in the entertainment industry
John Pryor has a deep fascination with
True Crime podcasts he also follows
controversial court cases especially the
invest education and trial of Adnan
Saeed that was thoroughly covered in the
popular serial podcast by 2016 crier had
already taken this hobby to Twitter
where he discussed theories with other
podcast hosts and those deeply
interested in the subject eventually
crier's social media interactions led to
his being asked by Susan Simpson of
undisclosed to host segments for the
second season of the podcast which she
enthusiastically accepted in an
interview with rolling stone Cryer said
I'm not a lawyer I just have an avid
interest in this stuff and the
undisclosed team was hoping that I would
host a fan interaction show like The
Talking Dead is for The Walking Dead
leading up to the 2016 presidential
election John Cryer became vocal about
his opposition to Donald Trump in an
episode of the real Pryor compared his
former co-star Sheen to Trump saying I
worked with a guy who also whenever he
said whatever came to the top of his
head people loved it and people loved it
even more when he said horrible things
crier explained that having lived
through it once those traits weren't
what he wanted from a political leader I
don't want people to pick the president
based on entertainment value after four
years of Trump's presidency the actors
outspokenness only increased and led to
a Twitter feud with representative Matt
gates in 2020 for his staunch support of
the GOP leader a month later Cryer was
so disgusted with the actions of the
president that he tweeted I'm a
registered independent voter I voted for
and supported both Republicans and
Democrats in the past but the chupi's
conversion to The Cult of trump has made
it clear I will never vote for another
Republican ever again period for a few
years leading up to its Premiere in May
2022 John Pryor collaborated with his
mother Gretchen to create a new play
series called True Stories the Stage
production was a collection of
individual stories by solo performers
about problems with men parent issues
and coming of age with crier's one-man
show being called the actor's nightmare
crier ultimately pulled various pieces
from his Memoir to craft a show about
his life experiences he told Spectrum
news NY1 it's mostly about my
relationship to starting in the theater
and it's ironically a love letter to the
theater even though it's got nightmare
in the title because once covet hit and
we were sort of robbed of any life in
the theater you realized what was
missing so I'd written a book years ago
that had a lot of stories about my life
in the theater and we realized there was
actually sort of a cohesive narrative to
it unfortunately crier unexpectedly had
to cancel all performances that sounds
like a true actor's nightmare doesn't it
John Pryor may not have made any
on-screen appearances in 2022 but that
also didn't mean he was absent from all
TV Productions instead the actor was
featured as the narrator for the vice
docu series devoured which tells the
story story of True Crimes associated
with food Pryor told deadline just when
I thought there couldn't be a genuinely
new Twist on True Crime I got devoured
while I can only aspire to the greatness
of saying Bill Curtis or Keith Morrison
it's an honor to lend my voice to this
Morgan Herson an executive advice seemed
just as pleased to have the actor
involved saying having as immense a
talent as John Cryer narrate devoured is
really exciting for us on top of Jon
Cryer's side projects over the last few
years the actor has also dedicated his
time and resources to the altruistic
goal of helping fight homelessness 69
000 people face homelessness in Los
Angeles County and LA mayor Karen bass
declared the ongoing decades-long crisis
a state of emergency in January 2023.
Cryer's response has been to help Supply
tiny homes for individuals who are
struggling with homelessness in the Los
Angeles area tiny houses are trying to
help house homeless people providing
them with amenities such as showers
laundry units and electrical outlets
Craig told E.T
this is a way to give them a real home a
real place with privacy and a place
where they can feel like a human being
again for an amount of money that isn't
going to crush people
[Music]